what if gon joined the Phantom troop
because he absolutely had the
opportunity to and actually his reason
for not joining was something along the
lines of I'll never become a kill
murdering guy man like you degenerates
then cut to the camera and talk and gone
is threatening to kill murder and
innocent girl for the sake of kite I
honestly think that no banaka was on the
money when he assessed gone as a
candidate there is a world where this
definitely could have worked and we are
going to explore it the premise here is
quite simple Nobunaga wants a friend
after uvigin was killed by a wrathful
blonde and buried in a hole there was an
emotional Gap to be filled in obanaka's
life he was on the dead best friend
equivalent of a rebound and so Nobunaga
took a bit of a liking towards gone as
many do be they assassins less formal
assassins or even serial killing battle
clowns gone is like a scum in villainy
magnet but in this case what nobunaka
really liked about gone was his brutal
and simplistic honesty and it's actually
shizuku who puts these words into
feelings in Chapter 93 when she equates
both gone and uvigin as people who wears
his heart on his sleeve flies off the
handle shows amazing strength when it's
for another person and after a manly
bout of arm wrestling against an 11 year
old child Nobunaga said look kid why
don't you join the spiders you could
team up with me nobunaka to which gone
replies no thanks I'd rather die than
join you an urbanaga Smuggler are taught
oh I'm hurt but honestly I think he is
hurt and it's very much like the meme of
that guy angrily crying under the happy
face mask Nobunaga is pretty determined
though he vows to non-consensually
incorporate gone into the Phantom troop
and while Fink says it he doesn't think
that Corolla would go for that idea I
kinda disagree becoming a troop member
seems to be far less of an exclusive
process than we thought particularly
with just how easily and casually
Carlito gained his membership as well as
illumi's old Dick's temporary spot and
recent chapters very much reinforced to
me that gone probably would have been
accepted because the Phantom troop do
have empathy for nen using children
because that's the thing it is they all
once were so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna go ahead and play narrative
God and instead of gone saying no thanks
he's going to say yes please and instead
of I'd rather die than join you gone is
going to say I'd rather join you than
die however for the sake of some sort of
reasonability we're gonna have gone join
the troop after York New City because
even in a hypothetical I just don't see
there being any world where he betrays
karapika at this point in the story
however after the spider business is
done gone is all about networking and
part of his agreement for joining may
even be that the troop assist him in
finding Jing now second big change
kilowa will also be joining The Troop
primarily because he's an 11 year old
boy who wants to stay with his best
friend and given that the trip have let
two zoldx one younger than kilowa very
casually join I see this as being even
less of a problem than gone's membership
in fact gone may be the price that
crawler was willing to pay to have
killer aboard that's the head though
what do the legs of the spider think why
would they so readily accept these kids
well by this point the original troop
members hypoconota's memories and she
was grateful to the two of them before
she died so there's already an
empathetic link with the original troop
members meanwhile the later candidates
like shizukub and all enough and
cortopia all extremely chill and easy
going so with this in mind and gone will
become spider number 11 taking over
again spot and kilowatt will take on the
mantle of spider number eight eight
being the unknown troop member who was
killed by silver zodik so it's nice and
thematically appropriate and funnily
enough from here the series plays out
kind of as we know it because both gone
and the Phantom troop are locked on to
the same destination being Greed Island
just instead of going through a terror
selection process the Phantom troop will
simply steal as many copies as required
giving gon and kilowatt access that way
our first big problem though is that
with the troop gone in kilowatt are not
going to train with biscuit which is a
massive part of their development
however they do have another Mentor
Nobunaga will become their Mentor in
bisky's place because he is the
designated babysitter as the one who
nominated them and it's really in his
best interest to train gone and by
association kilowa so that he can
re-establish his best friend Dynamic and
urbanaga's teachings may be much less
formal than biskies but he is still a
world-class Den master and yeah the boys
will progress much more slowly because
they don't have biskey's magical massage
to Fast Track but it's not like we're
going anywhere anytime soon but great
island arc does not end until the game
is over and without gone kilwa and
hisoka nobody is going to beat Razer to
attain plot of Beach and in this world
the DodgeBall match looks very different
because what we now end up with is Razer
versus the Phantom troop they'll acquire
as many copies of the game as they need
to fill this team in fact canonically
each and every living troop member did
enter Greed Island along with hisoka and
when we include gone and kilwa that
gives us a group of 13 players so they
only need two more to complete the
15-person team which could easily be
achieved by threatening other random
players into joining them kind of like
how feitan threatened the Blackwell
passengers to step through the nen
doorway The Troop also have a vested
interest in completing the game Finks
and feitan showed a competitive
curiosity towards the game in general
and it's also worthwhile because they
would be able to take a prize from the
game so like most of what they do this
is a profitable Endeavor and the
DodgeBall itself while it goes very
differently Razer is of course a
Powerhouse but he is now facing the full
might and full intelligence of the
Phantom troop so plotted Beach is easily
Acquired and if genthru is still going
to decide to be a problem month then
he'll be wiped out with relative ease as
well in fact beating genther may even be
a request from abingana in exchange for
his assistance in lifting crawler's
nankus Either Way Gone can then complete
the quiz and win the game so that we can
select our prize gone needs two card
slots to make in a company which leaves
one open for the rest of the trip and
honestly biskey's choice of blue planet
may not be such a terrible idea because
it could self acquire quite a bit of
cash money however I think there is a
much more useful card for the troop and
that card is sort of Truth the ability
of which is splits into anything and
anyone deceitful in Trials it's a
criminal's worst nightmare the sword
will shatter when used to cut something
true but will regenerate if stored in
its Scabbard for one day it essentially
fills parkinoda's former role as a lie
detector so it's a very useful
interrogation item and really it's
either that ordullian's virility pills
which states that a certain part of your
Anatomy will get very frisky both
endurance and frequency are enhanced one
vial contains 500 pills so that card
creates more euphemistic sword I should
also note that color still joins The
Troop and fills the number 4 slot his
motives are still unknown but if they're
to do with killer then joining the troop
is still very if not more acceptable and
if it's another brother then same thing
meaning that the troop now have three
children to take care of gone and kilowa
then use a company but they themselves
are accompanied by Nobunaga as he is
their designated babysitter so he'll end
up meeting kite with the two of them
they share some stories have some laughs
hahaha but in this world God has no
reason to stay with Kai because gone and
kilowa have this habit of Mentor hopping
from your wings to ubiscus to your kites
but since they still have a mentor with
Nobunaga and an obligation to the troop
there is no reason to take time off to
study insects with kite so they take
their leave and become entirely
irrelevant to the events of the Chimera
antar and it's entirely possible that
due to this kite does not die in his
encounter with Peter the reason why he
was condemned to a state of death was a
momentary lapse in concentration because
of gone so he does have a chance of
surviving and perhaps even going on to
join the extermination team in place of
gone and killer alright one tricky thing
now in this world kill probably doesn't
remove illumi's needle this occurred in
a very desperate situation to protect
gone which is an opportunity that will
not Arise at least not at this point in
the story and while certain troop
members like perhaps say yeshall Knox
May notice Killer's needle I think they
know better than to try and mess with it
and as for the ants themselves well I
think the sarcas a very similar
conclusion albeit with a much higher
death toll marowam and his Royal Guard
were all destined to die during the
palace Invasion because even without
gone Pito would have come with yupi and
shireproof to marawam after his fight
with netro and become poisoned in fact
someone could even kill Pito whilst
healing comedy Pito was completely
defenseless though however the biggest
differences are the losses on our side
gone and kilua were the reason why
melioron and ikalgo were recruited the
former of which being especially
integral to survival meaning that
Knuckles shoot and moral have a
drastically increased chance of dying
during the invasion in fact the whole
effect could end with a double KO The
Invasion team killing marowam and the
royal guard but they all die as well and
I suppose the exciting thing is that we
now live in a world where the full
potential of adult gone may be realized
in a few short decades because he
doesn't lose net you just keep steadily
improving until he becomes undoubtedly
one of the most powerful nen users in
the world meanwhile his involvement in
the antarct is either relegated to
fighting zazan Squad at Meteo City or he
may not be involved at all notably
nobunaka didn't go with the troop
because he had his own assignment
somewhere else so gone and kilowa may
very well tag along to be part of
whatever that was however this change
has a pretty significant Global impact
because gone doesn't lose nen which
means that we don't need alaka to heal
him so she's going to stay locked up and
as a result Leorio has no reason to
accidentally run for Association
chairman and this entire rock is a very
straightforward voting Affair I do think
that Cheadle still ends up as the
chairman because whoever wins be it
parastan or Jing they're both going to
resign because they have their own dark
Continental priorities the bigger
question is does gone take this
opportunity to meet Jing it's a very
public election and the troop aren't
massively busy at this moment so let's
say he does that might be a bit of a
problem because may have wanted to
travel with Jing if he still had nen but
in this world he's part of the troop and
whilst getting into the troop might be
shockingly easy leaving the troop is
another matter knowing Jing I think he
would use the troop as an excuse to
continue not being apparent and convince
gone that he still has responsibilities
elsewhere which means that God is going
to continue into the succession war
hisoka vs crolo plays out exactly as is
afterwards charl knock and cortopi meet
their demise and hisoka vows to kill the
entire troop except this time that list
contains gone and kilwa so in this world
the gone vs hisoka rematch may actually
happen and not only that but in this
world gone is much more powerful than he
becomes in the actual series because he
doesn't stop training and improving and
by the time he gets aboard the Blackwell
one it's impossible to say just how much
he's improved but it's certainly beyond
anything we saw priyador gone illumi of
course also joins The Troop for the
hisoka kill Fest but with one very
painfully minor difference in the actual
series he takes the number 11 spot which
now belongs to gone and so illumi would
need to take on either 6 9 or 12 being
shalnak pakunoda and kotobi's numbers we
also now have three zoldic siblings in
the troop so there are more zodiac
siblings working for the Phantom troop
than for the actual zeldick Family
itself but are you ready for quite
possibly the most massive change now
karapika will never board the black
whale 1 because he was recommended by
Leorio who was only approached because
of his election performance which never
happens so neither karapika nor layorio
are aboard the ship so Prince wobble
dies almost immediately after leaving
Port as do likely many other younger
princes because they're being guarded by
the squad of nen users that karapika put
together who are no longer there so
there's no one to Control the Chaos of
this war and things are going to get
very out of hand very quickly in this
situation my bet would be on saradnik to
win the war and provided the troop in
the hunter Association can deal with
Morena on the lower levels then he
becomes the next king of the kakin
Empire then he gets dumped on the new
continent all according to plan and what
happens to the troop from here is
unknown because honestly I'm still not
entirely sure what their actual plan is
even after killing and robbing the kakin
Empire they have no real way of getting
back to the human realm and not a lot of
reason to keep traveling to the Dark
Continent I mean gone may have some
desire to go because it was Jing's
desire and killer may follow him because
that's what pre-needle poor killer does
but much like the actual series events
from here are wildly unpredictable
however the major changes that gone
remains our protagonist and karapika
remains in a dark Cellar somewhere just
staring at the eyes of the kurta clan
but please tell me in the comments what
do you think happens from here